tatsächlich habe es auch hektische
überprüfen müssen meine eltern wohnen
schleswig holstein
ich komme aus kreuzberg das heißt ich
darf meine eltern zurzeit nicht besuche
ich habe dann genau noch mal nachgelesen
was dran da gilt also tatsächlich
empfangen meine eltern besuch auf einem
risikogebiet müssen sie bis zu 5000 euro
bußgeld bezahlen wenn ich dorthin reise
werde dann erwischt immerhin 3000 euro
das heißt es total chaotisch außerdem
kann nicht auch die quarantäne die 14
tägig quarantäne umgehen wenn ich zwei
corona tests machen müssen aber fünf
tage dazwischen liegen also das heißt
theoretisch kann ich natürlich meine
eltern nach wie vor besuchen aber nur
unter sehr wichtig sehr sehr strengen
auflagen mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bate schau dich hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren